elle a désormais pignon sur rue dans
l'univers du livre est la bd s'est même
fait une place au soleil dans les rayons
rien que pour cette année on dénombre
entre 5 et 6000 nouveautés sur le marché
c'est une immersion dans le monde du 9e
art à l'échelle régionale
une histoire de bulot man en quatre
épisodes voilà quelques temps maintenant
que la bande dessinée historique
s'invite dans les cours de récré très
exactement depuis trois ans et le
lancement de bulles de mémoire un
concours organisé par l'office national
des anciens combattants et victimes de
guerre la bd c'est un vecteur populaire
important et ont cherché à toucher les
jeunes citoyens les futurs citoyens de
demain à la halle aux histoires des
victimes des conflits contemporains ce
concours existe depuis trois ans au
niveau national et depuis trois ans la
normandie se place dans le top 3 des
régions participantes on voit qu'il ya
un vrai intérêt des jeunes générations
puisque concours s'adresse à des jeunes
de 11 à 20 ans l'histoire des guerres
depuis le début de l'année scolaire ces
élèves de 3e du collège andré collet
vivent dans leur bulle dans le cadre
d'un atelier pédagogique création bd
ils doivent mettre sur planche en
scénario avec pour toile de fond la
guerre
ailleurs on doit dessiner une histoire
qui raconte la guerre d'indochine
on l'a on raconte un peu comment ça se
passe le débarquement indochine la
guerre dans quelles conditions il dit on
raconte l'histoire d'une personne qui
racontait à ses monstres on a vécu pour
boire une bière généralement dessinée on
n'hésite pas à venir faire coller les
bulles sur les côtés de la case tout au
long de secours interdisciplinaire où
l'histoire se conjuguent aux français on
laisse libre cours à son imagination le
crayon devenant un véritable outil de
travail de mémoire
il ya eu des grands noms de la bd qui
sont intéressés à la gare etc ont
énormément travaillé sur la guerre comme
tardy notamment mais moi ce que je
trouve assez intéressant c'est que on
est dans deux sujets qui sont plutôt
opposés au niveau de l'ue les jeunes
vont être plus avoir du mal même si on
assiste au niveau scolaire à
s'intéresser à tout ce qui est des airs
et anciens combattants etc
alors que dans un public qui va plus
intéressé aux côtés guerre on va avoir
moins face à des personnes plus âgées
qui ont à la rend plus de mal abordé le
monde de la bande dessinée c'est vrai
que c'est une passerelle entre les deux
que je trouve vraiment intéressante
c'est ça qui est bien parce que ça
permet de mélanger plusieurs matières et
ça pourra se servir plus tard
ça permet aussi nos cultures
c'est intéressant ce type de projet il
est révélateur pour l'enfant quand le
jeune mais pour moi également de permet
de vraiment voir des élèves très en
retrait avec de grosses difficultés dans
cette discipline qui veut français par
exemple qui à travers le dessin ou le
scénario et le travail des équipes sont
vraiment mis en valeur et c'est très
bénéfique pour l'élève est aussi bain
très épais très enrichissant pour pour
le professeur que je suis parce que ça
interpelle sur leurs pratiques et puis
c'est toujours sympa de les voir en
activité il ya aussi une chose qui est
très important c'est qu'ils sont tous
actifs
donc quand on est dans le cadre de la
classe traditionnelle ils sont assis à
leur table il les écoute ils sont pour
la plupart passif en normandie près de
300 jeunes sont actuellement inscrits au
concours bulle de mémoires d'ici au 30
mars 2017
toutes les planches de bd seront
soumises à l'appréciation d'un jury
demain autre coup de crayon et traits
d'esprit sur l'expression de la pensée
citoyenne en compagnie du dessinateur j
rhum et eau